uh
uh
ugh
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
is
[Music]
ready for the next race already here
ready and waiting
you want to use your own ride or am i
bringing beast
will take my ride it feels more natural
to me
you get it of course yours it is meet
there
yeah rancho be right there see you then
hey v we're gonna take a look under the
hood before we start see if all is okay
and stay close just in case
this race is giving me all the wrong
vibes why is that
you got sixth street the mocks
gangs are well wrapped just a matter of
when it's
him hang on be right back
right go ahead this race is giving me
all the wrong vibes
why is that you got sixth street the
mocks
gangs are well wrapped just a matter of
when a temple goes nuclear
it'll be fine don't worry sorry i need a
minute to kick the tires before we get
moving
sure
[Music]
get out the bush
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cuts back
[Music]
trust me
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
electricity
[Music]
[Music]
trust me you don't want it with the
[Music]
[Music]
problem
watch our back they're moving to pass
dare him to try
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
hmmm
[Music]
[Music]
the industry
[Music]
wrc meanwhile
dare him to try
[Music]
found guilty of defamation and sentenced
to 10 years
all things considered i see a bright
light on the horizon for more
technologies
in the coming years congratulations to
v and claire
first place v oh my [ __ ] god we won
we're finals bounced yeah hell yeah
don't stop yet okay
what for need to talk something you
should know
okay sit down for a spell over there
wow quite the view
yeah me and dean we like to come here
wanted to tell me something
i mentioned dean before my husband yeah
wheeled to your heat right sweetest man
i ever knew
we were friends before my gender
transition he brought daffodils to the
hospital
it's a new beginnings he said were you
married long
12 years dean used to laugh that for our
15th
said he'd finally talked me into my
first implant
i was prepping some surprise
hey you mind if i ask why you don't
sport any chrome
i love machines v i do but i don't ever
want to become one
that weird a little i guess
but it's fine
dean only person who could have
convinced me to chrome up
but guests will never know if he'd
manage time
why tell me about dean meaning
why now
he died during a race last year the
final
not your standard fatality though
are you saying you feel at fault for his
death me
at fault why would you think that he was
flatlined by corporal eagle weasel
peter sampson exceptional walking rot
[Music]
your husband how'd he die exactly
we just powered into the final straight
samson peeling up the tarmac ahead of us
was clear we couldn't win so dean let up
on the chew
and then that snake slammed on the
brakes dean also had to
he lost control but isn't that how this
race works
you don't get it rhode was cleared to
the finish line
he would have won it was premeditated
what's the corpose deal doesn't really
matter was only ever another adversary
to me
but to dean dean and samson had a
history going way back
did something happen between him
dean never admitted anything but yeah
there was some kind of strife something
personal
to their rally rivalry when samson came
first
dean got hot and bothered
[Music]
right so this isn't business as usual
for you this isn't about winning that's
right
[ __ ] winning i want samson dead
and this is your best plan for vengeance
folks die on the track all the time
won't seem unusual at all
another day at the races in line with
the rules
[Music]
and me i guess you want my help to zero
in
killing samson matters more than taking
first
we have to make a choice
sorry i lied to you v
it means a lot to you this
so yeah let's bury the bastard
thank you this
[Music]
it's important i need it see you for the
final
that's right till then v
[Music]